[Music]
CBS mornings at 8 30. you know what that
music means the next mission impossible
movie is almost here and we were talking
the stars of this long-running franchise
for our mission and possible week we're
calling it Haley Atwell joins the cast
in Mission Impossible dead reckoning
part one she plays Grace and expert
thief in pickpocket who finds herself in
the middle of a high stakes Mission and
the clip you're about to see grace and
Tom Cruise's character Ethan race
through the streets of Rome
[Music]
who talks like that
[Applause]
pull over listen I'm trying to help you
Chris Grace was looking out for Grace oh
Grace was looking out great uh Mission
Impossible we are proud to say is part
of uh Paramount Pictures which is the
same company as CBS and first on CBS
mornings we are very happy to welcome
Haley Atwell here Haley thank you very
much for being here having me uh so you
were just saying as we were watching
that clip that some of those lines were
in the moment they were improvised yeah
we obviously we knew choreography wise
what the car was going to be doing and
what the dynamic of the relationship the
characters would be but there were so
many opportunities where they would say
just just try stuff so sometimes when I
was handcuffed to Tom though I'd have to
work out when he spoke to me whether he
was telling Hayley slow down or take a
left or if it was Ethan speaking to
grace in which case I didn't have to
slow down I could take a right instead
you know so it was it was exciting and I
think that's probably why it feels so
exhilarating watching it because you're
in the moment alive yeah how much
preparation went into learning how to
drive and the scene we didn't see which
is just after the one where that
accident happens you guys are hand
cuffed to a steering wheel and you're
kind of taking turns driving the vehicle
yeah isn't it isn't it I mean it was so
endearing and funny to think that of all
things Ethan Hunt is undermined by a
Fiat 500 but when I when I saw that that
was a little yellow car yeah that you
pick up exactly and it had a mind of its
own so this the steering wheel was so
sensitive so there's a moment where you
know he turns the steering wheel and the
car just crashed immediately and we're
like oh okay I guess oh can we yeah for
clarification those who don't know
um Tom is actually driving right yeah
there's an assumption that when you see
stunts and you see car chase you're on
the back of a trailer or something
you're being rude oh no we we and I'm
I'm drifting too I mean an answer to
your question I trained for five months
with an incredible team led by Wade
Eastwood to make sure that I knew how to
drift competently but then you learn how
to do that on a race track in the UK but
then when you get out to a location like
Rome these all these other moving
obstacles and so it it you know it
elevates the stakes even more wow so I
had to practice a lot you know Haley the
premier as you know was last night and
you you had one of the prettiest dresses
in the room I'll just say that about you
but what was so endearing to me is when
Chris the director and Tom came out one
of the best introductions when you say
Tony they said we don't call her Haley
we call her hail yeah that she's that
good what she does this is Tom speaking
is extraordinary and terrifying
impressive in every single way and Chris
reached out to Tom and say we have to
find her we have to get her that's the
person we want at the time they weren't
even quite sure you said what the
character was are you not afraid when
you're doing those things and if you're
not afraid of family members afraid for
you
yeah I mean I I was scared watching I
know it's a movie you know yes I when
when I did it we thought well let's have
Grace be afraid that feels that's human
that's real if she'd been slick and cool
and the stakes wouldn't have been as
high for her so if you would have sort
of been like oh she finds this easy so
we just kept using all of that you know
my both my parents have seen the movie
my dad was at the premiere last night my
best friend my cousins and they were
just like how do you do that I don't I
don't know it was you just do yeah you
display so many layers of your talent in
this film
um not just with the stunts but you're
acting as well you know you're described
as a master pickpocket
um so you still your wallet the key or
your heart which it seems like
as viewers but also Ethan's heart in the
film but what is it like you have in
your skill set your talent and then
working with a legendary man like Tom
Cruise do you learn from him do you pick
up things did you take anything away oh
it was it was a master class really in
not only work ethic and his incredible
manners he's so gracious and so polite
to everyone and hard-working but then
also his understanding of every
technical aspect of filmmaking so he's
very inclusive you know he invited us to
production meetings he would ask us to
watch playback to look at what the frame
was communicating and he's always
thinking objectively for the audience so
this whole film was designed going does
this Engage The Audience does it make us
Retreat from her lean into her so all
the way you're just finding watching him
he's finding moments of going how can I
excite and Delight the audience did he
want to know how you all were doing too
during the scene how you're feeling yes
to be very caring in that way to me yeah
he's he's very um attentive he also can
kind of read people so there's one part
of the film where there's a train
Carriage sequence that goes from
horizontal to Vertical yes seconds yes
and I'm hanging from it and I think it
was like our fifth take and I was kind
of we're waiting for the train to reset
so we could do it again and I was like
obviously jumped in the corner kind of
looking quite tired and he was like how
you doing it's like I I don't even know
at this point Tom I don't I don't even
know what I don't know
no but I don't know he went I think you
have adrenal fatigue and he presented me
with this beautiful box of chocolate
like out of nowhere and said he
presented you he was like you need some
chocolate that's going to wake you up
did that make a difference yeah I mean
it's going to make a difference to my
life in anything so so Tom Cruise is
doing these stunts with chocolate in his
pocket and now I bought us something
fall out of his pocket when he came out
of the motorcycle I don't know when that
train scene is amazing it really is yeah
it's amazing yeah and how are you
feeling this movie's coming out on a
Wednesday which by the way I've never
seen a movie come out on a Wednesday
when it's already gotten such critical
Acclaim how are you feeling about the
rest of the world that gets to see it
you excited about it nervous about it
what are you thinking I'm excited big
I've seen the movie myself five times
and it's because it's just so good and I
feel you know we're so proud of it but
even the whole filmmaking process every
single frame and scene was designed
executed edited with the audience in
mind and you know when I said to Tom you
know what is the running time of this
gonna be and he said it's going to be as
long as it is entertaining wow
that's such a good sign yes and it's
true it goes by so far you guys have
been working on this movie for how long
I came on four years ago four years ago
she learned martial arts uh had a thrift
pocket had a drift yeah don't run a car
to this lady
you got a lot of skills going forward
and we got a part two coming next week
you guys are filming that right now
right we are yeah we're about 30 and
we've got a long way to go the Simon
press tour is the kind of uh this is
your rest period right yeah and Simon
Pegg said part two is gonna make this
first one look like Elementary School oh
yeah this is a setup for the second one
this that this is like an introduction
of what is going to come next I can't
wait yeah hell yeah well thank you very
much you like action movies Haley but
you do so much more than action movies
yeah I'm classically trained so I did a
lot of theater I still do a lot of
period dramas adaptations of books
independent movies limited series and
then I kind of find myself in a
franchise I'm like okay it does it all
yeah
Mission Impossible dead reckoning part
one a complete movie unto itself really
great out in theaters everywhere
tomorrow